لقد أنقذوا معًا ملايين
الأرواح ومنعوا الإصابة بمرض كوفيد 19 الشديد، وقللوا من
العبء العام للمرض [موسيقى] [موسيقى] لذا فإن جائزة نوبل لهذا العام
تعترف باكتشافهم العلمي الأساسي
الذي غير فهمنا بشكل أساسي
لكيفية تفاعل السيد مع
جهاز المناعة وكان له تأثير كبير على
المجتمع خلال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قضينا ما تبقى من عام لا أعرف
أكثر من 20 عامًا في العمل معًا لمعرفة
كيفية جعله يعمل، وكيفية الحصول على
لقاح يعمل بشكل جيد وضرب و و
تم الاعتراف بفاعلية اللقاحات بنسبة 95%
والتي كانت في الواقع
نقطة تحول في مجال العلاج في Inna.
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق] [
موسيقى] [
تصفيق] [موسيقى] [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
INE أعتقد أنها جائزة جميلة جدًا
لأنها مرتبطة حقًا  معًا هذا
الاكتشاف الأساسي لما فعلته السيارة ووايزمان
كما سمعتم U منذ ما يقرب من 20 عامًا
عندما كانا يبحثان في كيفية
تعرف الخلايا على أنواع مختلفة من
[موسيقى]
RNA